could this be the car of the future
called the mirai from toyota its fuel
cell technology that drives her wheels
is so cutting edge the car giant
believes that in terms of innovation it
could overtake the prius
fuel cell stack is the heart of this
vehicle and furthermore the cell is the
key
including its reliability we put much of
the effort in reducing the size and
maximizing the power
but already there's a problem
new buyers will have to find fuel and
considering there are only a few dozen
hydrogen filling stations worldwide it's
an obstacle that could render the car a
non-starter for now most challenging
point for this car's rollout is of
course the infrastructure to get it's
kind of a chicken and egg type of a
problem
people want to buy the car only if
there's a infrastructure
but there won't be the infrastructure
unless people are buying the cars
costing just under 56 and a half
thousand dollars before tax the car
combusts hydrogen and oxygen over a
catalyst producing enough power to
accelerate to 60 in just nine seconds
and with the range of about 400 miles
between fills the release was timed to
reflect the global expectation that
hydrogen power will catch on
our goal of next year's release was
originally decided in 2011 when
infrastructure providers automakers and
the government announced their plans to
have the infrastructure ready we timed
it to synchronize with similar movements
happening in europe and america so we
went along with that
with toyota expecting hydrogen to be
cheaper to run a car than petrol
this green zero emission alternative
could go the distance